so whenever i meet couples who want to  learn one another's language  it's not actually that practical for  your husband to teach you russian  because he's so used to talking to you  in complex ways  in english that if if he hears you speak  russian  that that adjustment is a very difficult  thing so what you need is you need to  start  a new relationship with the language  teacher and  that relationship exists 100 exclusively  in russian  and then in your brain you start to  develop that i  need to use russian to communicate with  this teacher  and that helps the language flow the the  reason that immersion works for a lot of  people  it's because of that necessity that  forces them  to just push through the fact that at  the beginning stages  are difficult whereas with your husband  you don't need to use russian because  you can switch back to english yeah